und fasse ich mal wieder wird science
fiction zur realität in der dna einer
bakterie also im erbgut wurde jetzt
schadsoftware versteckt und auf diesem
weg tatsächlich ein computer gekapert
das ist wirklich unvorstellbar und macht
auch ein bisschen ans ab sofort können
auch bakterien computer infizieren
welche gefahren von bio hecking ausgehen
jetzt in kriegszeiten herzlich
willkommen
den eigenen computer mit einer erkältung
oder schlimmer anzustecken fast
unvorstellbar oder doch tatsächlich ist
jetzt so etwas gelungen erstmals wurde
ein computer auf biologischem umweg mit
einer schadsoftware infiziert aber
eigentlich noch schlimmer denn für die
bakterie oder den menschen war der coach
wohl ungefährlich erst im computer wurde
er in dem bakterium aktiv und verpasste
ihm eine verheerende krankheit
der ganze vorgang ist ziemlich komplex
aber gleichzeitig auch unheimlich
faszinierend
der erste schritt bestand darin eine
schad software zu programmieren einen
sogenannten exploit das werkzeug
überhaupt für alle hackers dieser welt
wurde programmiert dieser binärcode
wurde dann in einem zweiten schritt in
eine dna sequenz umgewandelt dna besteht
ja aus vier charakteristischen baustein
den nuklearen adenin thymin guanin und
cytosin kurz atg und c befindet teil
nicht so wichtig um das verfahren zu
verstehen wichtig ist nur das ist
einfach eine buchstabenfolge ist die
hier in die dna eingebaut werden muss
diese bestimmte sequenz die also von den
binärcode abgeleitet war lief ein
forschungsteam herstellen und zwar bei
einem kommerziellen dienstleister für
mich meinen neun stick soll aufsucht
wird habe ich es verraten es waren also
keine kriminellen ja und dann lagen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
diesen künstlichen dna strang wieder aus
in der rolle des opfers heißt wir nutzen
jetzt einen computer auf dem ein
programm zum auslesen von dna code
installiert war
einen weg wenn zierer damit wurden auf
den basen atg und c 1 und 0 um den
computer zu kapern verarbeiteten sie die
so ausgelesene dna-sequenz weiter etwas
ergebnis die sicherheitslücke die wie am
anfang des experiments in die dna
eingeschleust hatten produzierte
tatsächlich einen buffer overflow einen
sogenannten speicher überlauf hierbei
passen keine weiteren daten in den
pufferspeicher des computers diese
interpretiert diesen signal als befehl
eine verbindung zum steuersystem der
angreifer aufzubauen so wurde also
derjenige server kontaktiert der unter
der kontrolle der us forscher und
forscherinnen stadt knapp 40 prozent der
sequenzierte dna abschnitte enthielten
nicht das gewünschte schadprogramm bei
diesem unglaublichen experiment gab es
einige technische hürden zu überwinden
sequenz ihrer zerhacken dna stränge in
kurze abschnitte so dass der code der
schadsoftware in und kurz sein musste
eine weitere einschränkung die vier
wagen atc und g mussten relativ
regelmäßig vorkommen denn ansonsten
würde sich der strang in der backe der
dna strang zusammenfalten wert zu
instabil wurde dass unglaublich an
dieser geschichte ist einfach dass die
daten für den dna heck biologisch wenn
es gibt also keine altbewährten dateien
die den computer befallen sondern
tatsächlich bakterien gleichzeitig
bedeutet das aber auch die offenlegung
einer riesigen sicherheitslücke in
diesem sensiblen bereich denn natürlich
könnten so auch systeme die solche nicht
digitalen daten auslesen gehackt werden
iris oder fingerabdruck scanner zum
beispiel das heißt in einer kontaktlinse
oder einem künstlichen fingerabdruck
könnte schadsoftware verborgen bleibt in
der bioinformatik denkt jetzt aber
trotzdem niemand solch ein bio hecking
szenario eine große gefahr darstellt
zumindest heutzutage noch nicht dennoch
ist der aufwand für solch ein bio
hecking zu groß zunächst muss dafür erst
einmal eine entsprechende dna sequenz
erzeugt und in das gewünschte
sequenziell system eingeschleust werden
zudem hat die forschungsgruppe bei dem
aktuellen experiment gezielt eine
schwachstelle in die software des
sequenztyps eingefügt um einen erfolg
des angriffs überhaupt zu gewährleisten
professionelle hacker könnten so eine
lücke
natürlich finden was aber erheblich
aufwendiger wäre und es ist auch
tatsächlich so dass in kommerziellen
sequenzierung programmen ähnliche
verwundbare stellen vorhanden sein
müssen sind einfach zu komplex fehler
sind normalen programm befasst das
experiment ist also eindeutig gebraucht
werden bringen grundlegende konzepte für
mehr datensicherheit im bereich der
bioinformatik systeme müssen also nicht
nur gegen hacker angriffe aus dem
internet oder gegen infizierte
usb-sticks gesichert werden sondern eben
auch gegen biologische hacks denn im
worst case könnten hacker zukünftig mit
ein wenig fachwissen und präparierter
spucke als ausgangs element computer
kapern
künstliche dna wird derzeit außerdem von
vielen 1 das speichermedium der zukunft
gehandelt das experiment zeigt dass ich
dann auch speicherdienste gedanken um
ihre sicherheit machen wir bei pixum
halte ich euch natürlich auf dem
laufenden wenn er kein video zu diesem
thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann folgt mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter
mit bakterien als datenspeicher
da geht es um ein film der in einer
bakterie gespeichert wurde absoluter
wahnsinn also nicht verpassen und auf
klicken viel spaß dabei und ansonsten
gestank dran